hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
twitter is erroneously seen primarily as
a social network when it should be seen
primarily as an information network
twitter serves to disseminate
information quickly and can often drive
news cycles though from what i can tell
it's widely seen as a cesspit of
nonsense but in my experience if you
follow the right people the platform can
hold a wealth of knowledge from
scientists and engineers doing really
cool stuff
regardless twitter has now grown to
become the public square for politicians
celebrities and government bodies it's
become essential to a select few aspects
of modern functioning so when the news
broke that tesla ceo elon musk had
acquired a 9 stake in twitter to become
its largest shareholder people
collectively raised an eyebrow
in this episode let's see what's going
on and what it could all mean
you are watching
tv
tesla's elon musk revealed a 9.2 stake
in twitter worth nearly three billion
dollars making him twitter's largest
shareholder
jack dorsey twitter's co-founder only
has a 2.25 stake
jack who stepped down as twitter ceo in
november was the previous largest
individual owner
interestingly the next biggest owners of
twitter after musk a vanguard group
morgan stanley and blackrock elon
purchased over 73 million shares on
march 14 2022 but the filing was only
revealed on monday april 4th twitter
stock surged nearly 30 on the news
though twitter so far has remained
silent on the event
as everyone here is aware elon musk is a
very active user on the platform
with more than 80 million twitter
followers he regularly posts memes and
gets himself into all kinds of trouble
however what's interesting and has got
people talking is what he posted on the
25th of march 11 days after his
then-secret twitter stock purchase
on that day musk tweeted quote free
speech is essential to a functioning
democracy do you believe twitter
rigorously adheres to this principle
underneath the poll he wrote the
consequences of this poll will be
important please vote carefully
with over 2 million votes 70 of people
thought no myself included elon then
asked in another tweet on the 27th
quote given that twitter serves as the
de facto public town square
failing to adhere to free speech
principles fundamentally undermines
democracy what should be done is a new
platform needed
in the last episode of my podcast called
through the web myself and torsof
discussed this tweet we thought as many
others did that elon was planning to
start his own social media platform we
concluded that it would be an uphill
battle to get traction and user
retention but not many people if anyone
saw the next move from elon musk
so why did elon musk buy twitter
according to ed boyd a sky news business
reporter musk decided to buy the 70
million shares quote on a whim
eric gordon a law and business professor
at the university of michigan states
that it could be more strategic than
that he mentions that twitter could
generally just be a regular investment
and musk sees growth ahead
on the other side of the coin gordon
states that the purchase could be for
non-investment reasons like it was
hinted from his previous tweets in march
musk may just want to make sure that the
platform doesn't restrain free speech
but possibly moreover his speech
no chief executive at twitter would
refuse to take a call from the company's
top shareholder
so the purchase gives elon musk access
to twitter's top management
eric gordon goes on to say that the
purchase could cause a problem when it
comes to the topic of disinformation
we also discussed this topic on the
podcast
to me i like the idea of people being
free to say whatever they like even
ideas that i hate as long as it's not a
call to violence or an incitement to
cause other people hardship
if it's a bad idea or just plain wrong
the correct information would eventually
push it out of the sphere but i'm well
aware that this is just the ideal
situation
the other option is just to ban those
opinions but that has unintended
consequences it forces those ideas to go
underground and fester unchallenged
to solidify this concept i mentioned
that it was similar to the idea of what
switzerland chose to do with the russian
state media outlet russia today
obviously the swiss government didn't
support the ideas expressed but they had
the foresight to see that it was better
to expose the wrong ideas and counteract
them instead of just banning them
people generally come out with a better
understanding when two opposing
viewpoints have equal opportunity to
fight it out
but then again in such sensitive
situations as a war there are ideas that
could have instant negative consequences
what should be done then it really is
tough
who decides what is true and what is
false
who has a monopoly on the truth how do
you make sure that politics and
corruption doesn't distort the truth
just as a broad example if edward
snowden came out today he would probably
be labelled as spreading misinformation
and be banned
in the podcast episode i just ended up
saying that perhaps it's a deeper
societal problem it's a consequence of
the general difficulty of figuring out
the truth in any given situation
mainly because nobody can agree on
what's actually happening anymore
elon musk has not spoken specifically
about how he would change the rules at
twitter but i think it's safe to say if
he does do any action at all it would be
on the topic of free speech
an analysis wouldn't be complete without
mentioning that elon musk has previously
been at odds with regulators about his
use of twitter
last month elon musk asked a u.s judge
to nullify a subpoena from securities
regulators and also to discard a 2018
court agreement in which he had to have
pre-approval of his twitter posts
his lawyer had contended in court
motions that the sec is infringing on
the tesla ceo's first amendment rights
the controversy started after the tesla
founder infamously tweeted that he had
quote funding secured to take the
company private at 420 a share in truth
the funding was far from secured and the
electric vehicle company remains public
but tesla's stock price jumped
musk later claimed that the post was
just a joke referencing weed but both he
and tesla was fined 20 million dollars
each and he was required to step down as
the board chairman and provide
pre-approval for his tweet
some analysts state that getting around
this issue may be one of the reasons for
the twitter purchase
so what could happen next
industry analysts and legal experts say
that musk could begin advocating for
changes at twitter immediately if he
chooses in fact on april 5th he would
tweet do you want an edit button and
most people said yes
though it should be noted the security
document that musk signed indicates that
his investment role would be passive
meaning he does not plan to take control
of the company it remains unclear if
he's going to ask or be invited to join
twitter's board
still some analysts speculate that he
could alter the status of his investment
continuing to buy shares or even buy the
company outright
analyst for the research company cfra
angelo zeno writes
quote musk's actual investment is a very
small percentage of his wealth and all
in buyout should not be ruled out
according to bloomberg such a decision
could be very significant quote
twitter is particularly vulnerable to
outside pressure because unlike google
facebook amazon and snap the company's
founders don't have special voting
control over its future end quote
bloomberg goes on to cite how elliott
management indirectly forced jack dorsey
from the ceo position
as a result numerous social media users
have expressed concern over what musk's
share might mean for the platform
but what do you guys think do you think
that elon actually cares about freedom
of speech or do you see this as a way to
tweet whatever he wants about his
companies
feel free to discuss in the comment
section below
or if you want to discuss in more detail
head on over to the cold fusion discord
i'll also leave a link to my podcast so
you can check out our discussions about
this
if you want more cold fusion and you're
interested in the story of how twitter
started you can watch my episode on that
i'll leave a link in the description
it's a tragic story of scandal and
betrayal the story of a man by the name
of noah glass who helped build twitter
twitter wouldn't exist without him but
his name has since been forgotten by
history
okay so that's about it from me i
appreciate all your support for cold
fusion after all of these years you can
follow me on twitter if you like
alright so my name is digogo and i'll
catch you again soon for the next
episode
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]